تُظهر هذه الصورة داخل
طائرة شحن عسكرية أمريكية مليئة
بالدفاع عن اللاجئين الأفغان ، أحدهم ينشر الصورة
على الإنترنت يوم الاثنين قائلاً إن سلاح الجو الأمريكي
C-17 قد أخلت ما يقرب من 640 مدنياً أفغانياً في
وقت متأخر من يوم الأحد من
بين الرجال والنساء الذين
هربوا يائساً من الفوضى في كابول.
بما في ذلك طفل يحمل
زجاجة ، قال مسؤول دفاعي
للموقع الإلكتروني إن الطائرة لم تكن تنوي
استقبال الكثير من الأشخاص ، لكنه اتخذ قرارًا بالذهاب على أي حال ، عضو الكونجرس آدم كينزينجر الذي
عمل كطيار في القوات الجوية في
أفغانستان والعراق علقًا على
جهود الإخلاء
التي انتهكوها  في الأساس ، كل
تنظيم وتعبئة للقوات الجوية للعديد من
الأشخاص هناك وعلى المدى الطويل
سينتهي الأمر بإنقاذ حياة الكثير من الناس ،
عادةً ما تنقل الطائرات المشابهة لهذه الطائرة القوات والبضائع
حول العالم يُعتقد أن هذه الطائرة c-17
قال واحد من عدة شركات غادرت
مطار كابول يوم الاثنين وعلى متنه المئات
من القوات الجوية إنه من بين
أعلى المعدلات خدرًا.  من الأشخاص الذين سافروا على متن طائرة من طراز
C-
17 في عام 2013 ، قام طاقم بإجلاء أكثر من
670 شخصًا خلال إعصار في
الفلبين.
يظهر فقط
تقنيات أفراد القوة الجوية العظيمة
الذين كانوا يديرون طائرة الشحن تلك